[音楽]
あの若者を世界へというような亜大で話せということでございますけれども
まあこのところですね若干私が吉川持っておりますのはあ日本からの留学生が少なく
なっているんですね
私もはアメリカに振るぐらいとでも留学しましたし高校の時にアメリカフィールド
サービスと
いうことで留学いたしましたけれどもこのところアジア系の留学生例えば中国や韓国
からの留学生が増えているんですけれども実は日本からの留学生やてぃ減ってるんです
ねこれは問題だろうというふうに思いますあのやっぱり日本の若者はかなり宇宙気に
なっあるいは日本にいることがいい
にこのタフになったとまぁ日本も一人当たり gdp でもアメリカに匹敵するように
なってきてますからそういう意味では2国内にいることが非常に今2フルになってそれ
日本の人たちがあまり出ないというにょ私が留学しているころはですね
日本
の企業が留学生かなり送ってたんですね聞いところはそれやめちゃうんですね
なぜ辞めちゃったかっていうとあの企業留学したシソが帰ってきてその企業を辞め
ちゃうのが多かったですね辞めて他の会社に行くとか自分でなんかやるとかいうことで
ですね
企業はせっかくお金を払って送ってそれで破られ
注射を得ないと言うんで企業留学っていうのはなくなってしまったということですね
私はの大蔵省の留学制度できましたけどこそ今私の留学経験はマーカー
高校時代に1年でフライトで3年ということでその後も私はアメリカ
あー mf という国際通貨基金に4年ぐらいます
でその後またあーハーバード大学で日本経済論の講義しろっていうんで
あーまた大学で1年と合計アメリカ言いましたけどまぁそれが大変アヌーまあアメリカ
見たということはあの
アメリカおこう学ぶあるいは英語を学ぶというような意味もありますけれども一つ非常
にあの
大事なことです日本を客観的に見れるって事ですね
外へ出て日本を見て初めて日本っていうのは好意国なんだと比較してみてですねこう
いう国なんだとあるいは日本人というのはこういう性格を持っている
んだということがわかるんでやはりあのアメリカに行って日本というのは非常に意識
するようになったということで日本を知りたいっていうのは感じがかなり出てきたので
ね特に私はあの1980年から81年にですね
日本経済論というのを
ハーバード大学で講義をしたことがあったんですね確か私の購入は竹中平蔵さん年竹中
さんのあの日本経済論アメリカちゃいますけどもその日本経済論アメリカであの日あの
資料は十分準備して授業はあそこ
イージーができたと思うんですけれどもただおそらくその時のハーバートのキャンパス
で数少ない日本人だったと思います
木刀同時期に要請た日本人はもう一人ましたけども
小和田さんっていう小和田雅子さんのお父さんですね
彼が国際法を教えていて僕は日本経済のをせてるって
ような感じでございましたけれども
まあ数少ない日本人だったのですね
その日本経済論については準備したんですけどいろんな日本に対しての質問が出てくる
わけですね
で特に日本の歴史的な工法オベーションに関して質問が出てくると実は私答えられない
2月にもあったんですねでその時にいい
あの気がついたことは事実
諏訪私はあんまり日本のこと知らないなと
特に歴史的なことについてそれほど深い知識を持ってないなっていうようなことを非常
に意識しましたねこれはあのアメリカに行って初めて意識したことですからそれから
やはりあの
日本の歴史みたいなことをしっかりと学ぶ必要があるなというようなことを意識して
ですねええ
歴史いて4学ぶということが私の一つの園
まあアサイメントになったというようなことでございます
それからまたその時期にですねアメリカに行って非常に良かったのはですね
例えば80年81年あのハーバードで日本経済を教えたときは私は確か39歳ぐらい
だったんですけどその時ハーバー dqn mit の
非常に面白い時期でですね
here ラリーサマーズとも
をやりその時まああるいは
実はあの非常に頭のいい人ですね
博士事ってないんですねデハ稼ぐを取らないで教授になると舐めないんですけれども彼
の先生が確か
マーティフェルトしてないから語ったんですけどもお金の先生が本文頭いいから開かず
が取らなくていいと明かすがを取らないで教授んだっていいというふうに言われて
彼はあのその後もおそらくまあ名博士子みたいなもの貰ってるかもしれませんけども
その後も博士がとってないんですねまぁ何にせよ o
いうことで80年81年にサマーズとかサックスとか
あ車に知り合ったということで実はこれが結構後で役に立つんですね
私はその大倉車で帰って最終的なポストは財務官その前に国際金融局長という今国際局
長という名前になったんですけどそのときの最大の課題はですね円ドルレートが
初中にきちゃったんだね78円ということで
円高不況ってなことを言われたんですこの選んだがなんとかしてくれというようなまぁ
悲鳴が聞こえてきたというようなことでございまして
英国最近局長としての私の最大は仕事はですね円高是正ということだったんですね
でその私にとって非常にありがたかったのですねその95年っていうのは
そこに出てますけどロバートルービンさんねロバートルービンさんが財務長官に就任し
た時なんですね
ぺロバートロー銀座ご承知のようにゴールドマンサックスから来て
そのそれまではどちらかというと赤字解消のためにドル安政策をとってたんです
ミッキーカンターなんて言う人たちがところがロバートルービンさんは強いドルは
アメリカの国劇であるということを
財務長官になった時ってですね彼はあの
どの
金融出身ですからむしろドルが強い方があ
ニューヨークにい
資金が集まるんだとそのことがアメリカを征服するんだと
ですからドルが強いほうが実はアメリカを強くするんだというようなことを
その日私が国際金融局所でルイさんの下に悪さまーず0サマーズ私2
評価版
リティ secretary をやっててまあたまたまのサマーズハーバート時代から
知ってたんですね
かねっと連絡をとって強調管理するわけですね
日本は変だかで苦しんでいてなんとか
円安に持っていきたいとからアメリカのたまたまですね
方針変更して
強い取るということを言ったわけですねですから
国際収支を改善するために弱い取るということではなくて強いどれがいいんだという
ことをルービンが入ったということで実はアメリカと日本の間政策が一致するわけです
ね
たまたまフッ化両方のその
関西政策が一致したということもあって
それでまあしかも僕のカウンターパートはローレンスサマーズだったんです
これ気心が知れてたんでサマーズと電話をしてですねまぁともかく回入賞よと日本が
ソフト強烈に管理するからできれば今日仲介にしてくるとまぁ協調介入してくれたのは
3階に
海とか4回1回でしたけれどもまあ日本だけが介入した時もですね
歓迎声明を出さいうようなことをさまーずがやってくれたわけですね
ですからまあそれは日本とアメリカの整数が位置したということがベースにあったん
ですけれども私はやっぱりハワード時代に
伊佐正強くしてたぞそのまずの僕の
音を良くしてたということがやっぱり生きてくるわけですね
ですから若い時に留学するあるいは
仕事してるあの仕事に就いてから留学してそこだ高等 the 生ができるとまあ良い
友達わけじゃないんですけどそこそこで友達ができるとですねそれが仕事に生きてくる
ということが非常にしばしばあるわけですね
私の場合なんかやっぱりパロサマーを個人的に知ってたということが大変
プラスになって様頭の方もマーサが決まらならぁぁ
信頼できるだろうといういう風に考えてくれたんだと思いますけれどもそれが非常に
生きてきたんだけどね
そんなこともあって私が大蔵省で
財政金融研究所症という正局長になる前に
研究所の社長をやったわけですけどもそれ
の時に確か
ラリーサマーズとジェフリーサックスと
スタンレーフィッシャーという mit でこれはさまず先生ですけどもスタンバイ
フィッシャーと3人日本に呼びますですね
彼なら確か3週間くらい微妙に滞在したそんなことであの
サマーズさんも結構に本数になったと思いますけれどもそういうことでまぁ大学時代
あるいはその前のその人間関係っていうのはですね
私の仕事の上でも大変その
おいきたというようなことがあるわけでございますですからあの
皆さんもフルライトで留学するというようなことがあるかもしれませんけれどもその時
のやっぱり友達っていうのは大事にしておいて
一生の友達になる可能性が結構あるわけですね
あのそういうことで私の場合にはそこで知り合った人たち
ミシガン大学で知り合った人たちあるいはハーバードで知り合った人たちというのが
あの家その何人かあその非常に大事な友達になってそれが仕事に生きてきたということ
があるわけですからやっぱり若い
1に留学してですねそういう所に行ってですね
友達をつくっていくということが後々非常に生きるということになるのではないかと
思います
冒頭に言いましたようにですね
日本人の留学生が減っているというのは非常に私はある意味では危機感を感じている
わけですね
一方で中国の留学生とか韓国の留学生が増えているのに日本の留学生が減っていると
これはに本土企業にもやっぱり相当問題があるんじゃないかと思うんですね
2年ぐらい留学して帰ってくるあるいは3年留学して例えば博士がをとってくるとそう
いう人たちを日本の企業というのは必ずしもいう
しないですね企業だけじゃなくて浣腸もそうですね
私も大蔵省から送られてですねええ
まあカラーリングする時を暮らしは今の財務相はですね
残暑から留学する時は大体2年なんですね
2年で終止符を取ってこいというようなことでだいたいいくんですけど僕の時はですね
3年いればなんとか履かずは取れそうだというようなことがあったんで
三位してくれとさんにょろ
なぜをとって変えるというようなことだったんですけども
その時は一大きい出してくれたんですけれどもその時はしぶしぶ ok を出してくれ
たんですね
その時にまあ人事課長は非常にリベラルな人ですけど
人事課の方さが私に言ったことは女ハ
カサゴなんかとってくると一生研究職だと多くのショーでなくならないかというような
ことを言われたのを覚えてますけれどもそれでもいいですよと言って渡してや
まあ3年でなんとか取れそうだということで
の博士がを取ったわけですけどそういうことで
役所自身も
あの
留学してですねそれなりの勉強するということに対して必ず塩熱心ではなかったと
この頃変わっているかもしれませんけれどもその辺のところはやっぱり
まあ企業もですね館長もですねやっぱり
若いうちに留学させてそれで経験させるということが非常に大事だということを私は
認識してほしいと思いますねさきほども言いましたように日本からの留学生が減って
いるというのはですね
おそらく企業とか
館長の理解みたいなものが若干工法を低くなってきたということが関係あるのかもしれ
ません
しかし若いうちに留学するということは本人にとって非常にプラスですしまたその組織
にとっても非常に大きなプラスになると思うんですね
私も大蔵省で若いうちに留学
そしてで正局長んだった時財務課になったときにその時の知り合いと掛け合いをし
ながらですね色んな仕事ができたということがあるわけですからそういう意味で
栄和会うちの留学というのはぜひみなさんにも続けて頂きたい子ですね
企業なり組織もですねできるだけ若い
1に留学するということがあ
大事だということを意識してほしいとまぁフルブライト応用制度というのはそういう
ことでずっと昔からですね
日本人あるいは他の国の人たちの留学というのをサポートしてきたわけですけれども
今やフライトだけじゃなくていろんなところがこのサポートするシステムができてきて
いるわけですから
若い皆さんはできるだけ早くですね
できるだけ早い時期に
留学をしてですね迫で外国を学ぶということをしてほしい
繰り返しになりますけど外角を学ぶということは日本を学ぶということなんですね
日本っていうのを総体かしてそれで日本っていうのはどういう国なんだと
実は日本というのはかなり特殊な国なんですよ比較してみると歴史が始まっていないね
他の国に全く侵略されたことのない国なんて2本試験ないわけです
まあ7年間の占領期間というのがありましたけれどもね
そういうことで非常にユニークな国ですねそれから日本っていうのは平和な実験非常に
なかった
江戸時代265年全くない何もなかったですし
平安時代の360年ぐらいもその
全くその内覧もなかったということで他の国が
方がいる2戦うして
たとき日本が非常に平和なその
あの時期を遅らせたけどねですからその平和の配当っていうのあるんですね今日本は
おそらく世界中で一番安全な国です
犯罪率なんてなじゃあにくいが殺人の比率なんか非常に低いですねそれやはり長い平和
の一つの配当ではないかという風に
って居るわけで我々はやっぱりそういうに方ちょっと部屋は保ってきてですね
極めて安全でまぁ環境も非常に良くて
そういう日本大事にすべきだと思いますもう一つ日本ということで言えば日本人という
のは世界世界中で一番健康な悲哀10州から健康寿命大世界一安全あるいは健康と
いいで世界のトップランナーである日本というのを意識してそれを維持するという努力
が非常に大事ではないかと思います
時間になったようですからああそれではこれで私の話は終わりにさせていくありがとう
ございます
榊原さんありがとうございましたお忙しいなかあの本当にこんな若い買いに来て頂いて
ありがとうございます
どうでしたがこのようなステージはいやいや別ギアのシャベルの慣れていますから
15分とか18分たらちょっと短いですけどねなんですね
くっついませんあのルージュが厳しくから本日は有難うかわりハイさ
いっ
はいっ